[Music]
my name is Miles Morales and in my world
I'm the one and only spider-man that is
until he showed up and it snow on the
Cape I think it's cool spider-man
doesn't wear a cape hey guys
who are you I'm Gwen Stacy I'm from
another another dimension
how many more Spidey people are there
hey tell us this could literally not get
any weirder it can get weird my name is
Peter Parker how am I supposed to save
the whole world
you can't think about saving the world
you have to think about saving one
person miles where did you go spider-man
turn invisible not in my universe this
is incredible some kind of fight or
flight thing what's that I think this is
a cape my name is Peter Parker I'm
pretty sure you know the rest I think
the city fell in love then I saved the
city again and again and again look I'm
a comic book serial I get a Christmas
album and it's soso popsicle but this
isn't about me
not anymore spider-man swings in once a
day zip zap zop in his little mask and
answers to no one I love you more dad I
love you
better car my name is Miles Morales
the one and only spider-man at least
that's what I thought give the
supercollider you don't love this
you're like me that's impossible
all right kids listen up this prize is
your universe
soggy it's weird it's gross and this
delicious normal fry is my universe so
you want to learn to be spider-man teen
teacher yes I can
time to swing good double tap to release
and quit it out again whip and release
your natural quit hey guys
who are you I'm Gwen Stacy I'm from
another another dimension
how many more spider people are there
hey fellas this could literally not get
any weirder it can get weird okay we
need to get back to our universes soon
Brooklyn is gonna collapse my family
lives in Brooklyn whoa this was never
your city
[Music]
it's fine if I don't destroy the
collider none of us will have a home to
go home soon
what makes you different this well is
what makes you spider-man officer I love
you do animals talk in this dimension
cuz I don't want to freak him out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]